authoritarian systems evolved you know
authoritarianism in the Internet age is
not your old Cold War authoritarianism I
am Nicholas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with Rebecca MacKinnon the
author of the consent of the network the
worldwide struggle for Internet freedom
Rebecca is also a fellow at the New
America Foundation and a former reporter
in China for CNN Rebecca thank you for
talking to us that's right the book has
been widely reviewed and mostly
positively reviewed even the people who
have semi pay in the book have said it's
one of the most important tech books of
the year talk about the suppression of
Internet freedom around the world first
and then let's bring it home to the
United States or to the west I was a
journalist in China in the 90s when the
internet first showed up there
commercially and you could first get an
internet connection in China about 1995
and we the Western press just assumed
there was no way the Chinese Communist
Party could possibly survive this thing
and we were pretty wrong right and this
one built the Great Wall I'm all right
yeah they started blocking websites
what's happened and this is starting to
happen in other countries too is that
authoritarian systems evolved you know
authoritarianism in the Internet age is
not your old Cold War authoritarianism
the government knows that China's
economy has to be connected to the world
it's info information systems need to be
connected or they won't be successful so
what are the ways in which we think of
old-style authoritarianism it was just
right or you're killing enough people
until people lost interest now it's
their kind of balance that it's not
about total control it's about keeping
enough control and being manipulative
enough that you stay in power they block
you know a lot of international websites
like Facebook and Twitter and YouTube
but there's also all these Chinese
companies Chinese Internet companies
running Chinese versions of all the
possible social media sites you could
think of in that space though is there
still revolutionary
potential in the Chinese version of
Facebook and of YouTube where it ends up
to a point where it it actually does
provide that space for the conversations
that the government doesn't want to be
happy it's hard to say I mean so far
they've managed to control enough that
conversation still hacked happen but
people can't use those tools to organize
as soon as people start using them to
organize action around the conversations
people start going to jail accounts get
shut down etc the question is will it
scale like when you get another 200
million Chinese Internet users will they
still be able to control it that what
your suits do you think or well you know
they've surprised us so far I think
they're going to have to evolve they're
going to have to get more sophisticated
and in a way a little bit less
authoritarian will they go all the way
to actually being a multi-party
democracy you know having an independent
judiciary it's hard to know they could
just become kind of soft or
authoritarian when I think of kind of
cultural studies or cultural criticism
of Technology you're very much coming
out of a tradition of people who say
look you we should never pretend that
technology is past or that users are
passive we need to be active what are
the ways you think in a domestic context
that people should be most active I
think what it means is constraining
power and holding power accountable and
that's what democracy's always been
about that's what a you know a liberal
free society liberal with a small L has
has always been about it's been about
draining power and making sure you know
those who hold power over our digital
lives be the government actors corporate
actors or other actors that we
understand how they're exercising power
I would argue that they're the type of
power that government exercises is
different than corporate power so for
instance AOL which was one of the great
fear mongering epidemics of the early
21st century the way we exercise the way
that consumers or web users you know use
power they push back against AOL by
evacuating it essentially it's a lot
harder to do that if it's the FCC you
you attack it differently so what is the
primary threat of corp
power and what is the primary threat you
know coming from government power t of
thing corporate power is obviously
different and it relates a lot of times
to how much choice the user has no do
you have an alternative to Facebook that
actually accomplishes what you want do
you have an alternative to comcast in
your market and so on and sort of in an
ideal perfect market you probably
wouldn't need regulation because there'd
be so much choice that you know
platforms would be hyper respectful of
your privacy because you leave
immediately if they weren't and yeah you
know ISPs would be perfect and we
wouldn't be mad at them and so on but
it's not a perfect world in this country
there's not a lot of choice for
consumers there are times when
regulation makes sense and then there
are other times when law just can't keep
up with the technology and that we need
to be more innovative about how we hold
companies accountable and you think that
privacy is the I mean is privacy the
main issue that worries you about
corporations its privacy and its
manipulation of information so but
privacy particularly as pertains to
surveillance concerns me greatly because
ultimately what I think is the most
insidious thing is when you have a
combination of unrestrained corporate
power combined with unrestrained
government power and actually whether we
hear about this all the time where
companies are turning over information
to and the companies aren't being held
accountable for sometimes collaborating
with illegal government behavior and the
government's not being held sufficiently
accountable where I get most concerned
is when you have companies that you know
as they're collecting a lot of
information about us a lot of which
we're giving up voluntarily for you know
reasons for my reasons we effectively
yes you know we're willing to make the
trade-offs we might not be quite so as
aware as we should be about how that's
being used and then how might that get
used politically right by a government
that abuses its power to access this
information and how do we ensure that
those constraints are in place the kind
of ad hoc
you know coalition that grew up to
destroy so by of it you were against
SOPA I sure is that a model for how not
that the internet will be regulated but
you know that interventions will happen
to maintain some semblance of freedom on
the Internet do you think that's a
working model yeah and one of the things
that I talked about in my book is the
need for a movement we need a public
movement to protect the internet and and
to get people engaged in that and the
anti SOPA PIPA movement was very much
that and making it clear I think two
people in Congress who oftentimes kind
of assumed that particularly on these
technical issues the public's not paying
so much attention I mean the public
generally hasn't paid too much attention
to copyright law and then suddenly
people woke up and said wait a minute
this is you know in in protecting
seeking to protect copyrights don't
infringe other rights please you know
people really mobilize the cliche is
that oh you know younger people grow up
with the internet and they're actually
more savvy about it to be honest is that
the father of two kids I don't see that
do you I mean is there a reason to
believe that younger users you know who
grow up in an Internet world who take it
for granted are they going to be you
know hacktivists out of the womb or
what's the kind of education they need
to to get kids today tend to assume they
know more than they do which thankfully
when we were kids what we do better yeah
issues of not really thinking through
that oh I post this stuff on the
internet and it might have real
consequences for real purple people you
know what are those consequences for
myself a few years down the road and
things like that I just care about party
pictures you know but also what kind of
information or who's reading this
information absolutely yeah just a lot
more awareness about how this digital
world works how power is exercised
through it and what you need to do both
to protect yourself and also to make it
kind of you know the type of place that
that's pleasant for yourself and
everyone else well leave it there I want
to thank rebecca mckenna and she's the
author of the consent
of the network the worldwide struggle
for Internet freedom thanks for backup
thanks very much for reason TV I'm Nick
collecting